our weapons are he has decided to use a
bo staff that's good but liquor though
what are you gonna really do with a bo
staff
I can't believe you're gonna be
challenged on your own radio I start I
start swirling that thing around it is
gonna be on tyrant it's like a cheer
squad in a parade or something start
doing some shoulder punches you shut up
I'm saying so during that stupid Hong
commands big Jay oakerson I am we are
women reborn on the on the dog I've seen
Florence in the machine it was a real
awakening for us Lou I have to say you
missed out Oh crazy times
I should have been called period the
musical yeah it felt like the way that
Florence ran around the stage it felt
like when one of your little cousins
makes the whole family watch her sing a
song she also could sing like a mother
for everything in the world as you need
now a nice hot disclaimer but her voice
is amazing yeah she's a great front
woman stage design foolish age designs
cool her voice is next-level
and her performance is and what she
gives to the fans yeah fantastic
fantastic the music's not my cup of tea
yeah musics not you it was fun to watch
you at certain points I knew which
moments I think I know you well enough
that I know which moments were the eye
rolling back in the head where she's not
was very from the from the opening after
her first song she goes then we were all
very excited that we were about to be in
a sit concert and then she instructed
everyone to stand up and then 99.8%
women that were there yeah all obliged I
was gonna say I leaned over to Ari when
she said we have Florence in the machine
how could we have Bert just ran out
Silver October is just not getting drunk
who she's uh like she would hate me the
human being she shouldn't but she that's
the overwhelming feeling I got at that
concert well they were sucked through
the crowd the part that made us really
laugh was there as a part she was doing
a song off her new album called Patricia
which is dedicated to Patti Smith and
she said you know it's about Patti Smith
well the beginning in the ending are the
middle is about toxic masculinity like
being are you were joking really we just
kicked Jay down the stairs like I do it
to you I wasn't to Christine when she
goes because I like being in a place
where this nut toxic masculinity suck my
dick you bitch no shoes you shouldn't be
out the kitchen
just bring a 1950s dad into a foreword
to the Machine know what to bring up
that moment what I think the my grand
scheme problem with the world as it is
stands today yeah
there's so many people that concert
including I believe Florence herself
would absolutely call me toxic
masculinity but they're just aiming
there they put the wrong people in their
crosshairs for stuff like that I'm not
in the crosshairs I'm not popular you're
out of it you're also out of Florence
and the Machine concert absolutely but
I'm just saying the idea that like it's
a roomful of people one of my biggest
gripes I use this example a lot is I'm a
person who goes again do it goes why we
should try having like a broad in the
white house like you know chicken the
White House man see what goes
and then go a chick abroad and you're
like I'm just trying to say the funniest
word man I'm with you I'm on your team
yeah yeah but it's like you have to
fight through all that it's like you
you're you're upset at the present even
though the president is what you are cuz
you know like the wrapping paper
absolutely I want to get into it more
maybe we can get into it with our guests
even but our first guess is here first
of two guests we have today come in he's
coming in the studio now very excited to
see
not on camera camera day cameras cut you
can oh that's probably us as people yeah
I everybody from Blues Traveler and more
notably Z rock where he played the
character of John popper is my buddy
John popper everyone go to the bonfire
John popper just warm on up dude you're
on the radio tour today huh you know is
it like you're running for Senate it's a
little like a gangbang yeah like a
Houston one charge go on would they like
put ice packs on her and stuff yeah well
no with no Lube it all dry you separate
a guy in a gas station sir shirt
coming in pantsless yeah yeah somebody
looks a little like guilty but also like
you know gleefully like dazed yeah I
think that's who we are in this radio
gangbang guy that comes in with his
t-shirt still on do we like Oh big fan
of your work smell of skin in friction
oh yeah my t-shirts on and my and my
dicks just coming through the pee hole
yeah yeah I'm not gonna show you guns at
a gangbang good with all those ABS there
I'll let your gun fly free come on a new
sex organ I'm starting a therapy on
Friday so we're gonna see if I can get
there eventually you're starting therapy
can you believe it I know I definitely
fifteen easily 15 years later absolutely
Dan's been uh been pushing me on it
finally yeah take me to see Florence in
the machine last night so I realize it
was necessary you got a lot of stuff
there I go what's floating around in
Ujjain he goes anger Florence and the
Machine will do that too boy it sure
will yeah I walked out of there went
home and immediately shaved the Hitler
mustache into my pubes it was such a it
was such a celebration of woman plays
their band of therapists yeah as at a
time at the seventh song in there was a
just a procession of dudes just running
out of the general like and it was like
seven to one guys leaving
and then like a girl behind go like but
I just want to watch one more song
go I hung into the whole time while
Christine danced like a gypsy Queen by
the way Jake hung in there yeah Jay
called something on the show yesterday
he said whenever Christine gets into a
song my name is Ed that I just said how
long do you think what's the over-under
or how long before you look over to see
Christine like this hands clasped not
clad like in a praying motion forever
just with their mouths open just like I
haven't been making the songs and he
just hit like song to just nudge me
doing a faux Indian dance no just like
it's the I Dream of Jeannie thing yeah
no it's more of a pointing even forward
just like like she's trying to shoot her
her heart beams to the stage it was a
Wiccan ceremony when you look out when
you're when you're performing you look
out you ever see people dancing the
audience like what the is that yes
and that's why I try never to look out
just wish him into the corner nice weird
just a ginger girl just ripping loose in
a middle of a circle that no one she's
not really dancing to the song itself
it's all off my favorite is from a long
time ago and you know back when people
would play you dance at our level yeah I
know we didn't have a stage and there's
this like hip-hop guy you know popping
and locking me chick you know doing her
like weird ever expanding the angles
thing and they bump into each other got
their eyes closed and they're all like
into their thing and then they bump into
show like oh excuse me they're like so
polite yeah let me forgive you as a
robot they both broke characters have
you ever seen someone dancing me like
that guys in trouble we need to stop
like he's up we need yeah I think
once or twice I've stopped and said wait
no dude just stop it just stop that
Jimmy spritz bottle like a cat earbuds
you listening to the worst is throwing
harmonicas in the crowd because like he
always invariably throw to the tiny
little girl yeah you know the little
hippie chick we've already created this
idea that she's like oh little beautiful
hippie chick and to like frat guys on
each other elbow to get it and you see
her go blank
nothing in that brain going on anymore
and she goes down and dissolves into the
crowd and here's the scary part you
never seen her again like not even a
stain on the floor like go what be happy
that bitch got blood on my co-ed
naked lacrosse shirt too soft
Jesus Michael wait my Jordans are ruined
Oh bro dude I love hooks oh I
elbow tore ass master for the harmonica
that's gonna be on the mantle of Phi
Beta Kappa write himself he was you see
that's her teeth marks are still in it
from when I jaw door when she started
playing it I swear to god I've got had
people write with a bloody impression of
a harmonica on there before dude I
totally caught one of your heart what a
fun instrument that can turn so violent
when you're trying to give it away
throwing star of the world yeah it's the
bonfire company central radio sirius XM
95 big Jay oakerson day and so door hi
John popper is gonna join us back again
downstairs ripping a but he's ripping a
but he left us he's not the harmonic in
this place though it's so he's badass
it's weird listening to this song and
looking at the harmonica and you're like
is it gonna wake up also joining us in
studio his new film eighth grade is out
now he directed so cool to watch all
these things happening form it's Bo
Burnham joins us in studio accept me
guys we've been wanting to have you over
for a while it's awesome glad to be here
yeah dude thanks for coming on man
you've known Jay a long time yes since I
was seven 17 17 because it was before
just for laughs I hear so it's like
maybe June or May or April and I was
there with my we went to London yeah
went to London do the world stands up
world stands I was at a festival no it
was a weird black Evi show like a
British premium blenders okay everyone
from the mostly Americans was one of
those cool things were they send like a
camp out of like American comics okay it
was a weird mishmash strange
did they give you like like Olympic
track suits yeah the team
it was me you Tom Wilson who plays Biff
and back to the future in action it was
on a show I made a few years later Jamie
kill Steen Jo koy yeah who was just like
destruction at that point probably still
is but like oh yeah 2007's jo koy was
just just murder just lighting he was
murdering he's knocked all the gross
teeth out of their face with laughter
one of the funniest moments Tom Wilson
who plays Biff yeah most of his sets
about being Biff and then back in the
green room of the show jo koy goes I
thought a pretty fair question Oh
incredible
he goes what's your uh is what's your
favorite incarnation of Biff that you
played it was the West one or there what
a great question great question I mean
he's went come on man and as I closed
his Bing and like huffed out of the room
it was like what did I say go I guess he
doesn't like talking about being Biff
off stage you know I remember the the
British tour guy that brought us around
asking going you know who you look like
he goes you look like a combination of
Biff and like an older actor dasha
desperation if you were another
incarnation of beef but if he was warm
down and sad and he's like I was Beth
he's like yeah so I think Joe was coming
off the heels of that yeah that's a good
man do you recall a noise great guy and
we get along very well
did you but here with all my father I do
recall your father you're 17 she had
escorted see your dad what's that like
getting into comedy you're going to tape
a show in England and you're like dad
has to come with you because I remember
like getting dropped off at school
you're like mom leave me
yeah yeah that's pretty rough and like
that was the third or fourth time I had
ever performed yeah I've got like the
Internet so there's some awful like it
literally my third or fourth set ever is
take even yeah you're 17 yes the way
though everyone was pulling for each
other though yeah we came like a weird
I remember I remember the songs the
dictator taught
yeah Hitler yeah yeah it was
really really coincide first was like so
cheery yeah yes Mitchell did a
prince impression and I stood up like I
was at the Apollo yeah see this
we need more international comedic
competition yeah yeah you did really
well though I never you completely rift
on the night it was like beautiful thank
you that was unlike last I fell from all
of us
yeah see you a non-final for the
American yeah final from the American
speak Jay do you recall the warm-up show
which is my favorite store just the
warm-up show we did at the Country Club
yes I've told the story I don't know on
this show before I don't think you had
uh
but I don't want to say her name but
there's a calm we haven't said her yet
so I'm okay with that
the experience there's a female comic
yeah who enter jokes she just does a lot
of like like what I said who said yeah I
know you know yeah she we would this
warm-up set like a country club a decent
show though I remember everyone having a
pretty good time
she was once but they just didn't catch
him happens yeah I mean she didn't catch
the crash that happens when you're in
Milton Keynes just a funny as heck oh
I've ever done with all that I think
when she started getting nervous there
was a bunch of like it was just an
over-the-top amount of the what who said
it I said a guy in the audience there's
like a hubbub in the audience and one
guy gets up with like starts like a
quarterback he's calming everybody's
like I'll sound guy yeah I guess excuse
me miss who are you talking to
it was just the most deflating thing
I've ever saw again youch I mean the
British just cutting bone deep it's a
long tube ride home rubbing back of a
person gonna be stupid England they
don't even get one revolted yeah comedy
is an American thing dude where's the
man stayed up got America why do you
think they brawl so out here cuz II
don't know how to do it themselves I
mean I was asking question yeah that's
kind of Minnesota
excuse me pulled me who in the you
said watch miss
really believe you're speaking to anyone
in general are you babbling you're crazy
she's crazy oh they do it like
Manchester this hardware like Oh
like she would not that's got to be
tough because that's there's some
heckles the war ii ever got was at the
cellar this it was like probably I want
to say two months after I got past the
cellar it's a Friday night I was so
excited and this girl got up and she was
saying something to her boyfriend I miss
is there a problem she has I saw you two
weeks ago you're doing the same jokes
and then walked in with Bill Maher and
they sat and I was just like doing he
was like just at the cellar for some
reason me and you smoked a joint right
after my set in the stairwell and Bill
Maher walked out anyone heard great
stuff and he walked out and you go oh
nothing on mine but that was that night
and I remember that because it was such
an accurate heckle cuz she was basically
know the house she finished in she goes
I heard those jokes and I was here two
weeks ago but go ahead kill him in front
of Bill Maher the king of turnover
perform both for not your audience like
at all oh that's a that's a great
question I mean I don't like to do
Poppins light a little bit me I haven't
really done it in a few years or like
I'll do like Largo and stuff in Los
Angeles but I wouldn't call that not my
audience right John popper back in the
room got it smoking but feeling good
John bo burnham boburnham John popper hi
John John you were in my girlfriend's
movie the meddler yes that's what range
to wrote and directed that oh she really
appreciate you be thanks a lot it was
really cool yeah it's so fun to get to
do he got he did a set at the in a ferry
yeah yep we were in the boat and it was
really cool our dog basically
intimidated Susan Sarandon s dog yes
bitch
yeah her dog was really nice and well
behaved in our dog was a scruffy little
homeless
yeah that was a proper term Jay finally
finally had it in contact people we were
talking about hecklers like the ones
that hurt because I was saying a woman
got up during one of my sets at the
Comedy Cellar was like oh I heard these
jokes two weeks ago but go ahead and
tell them and I just froze up oh nice
have you ever been heckled I'm starting
to do like a solo show where I actually
start to get my little stand-up rocks
off yeah cool part is if I start to suck
I got a song it's always a birdie and
the thing I get run into is that it's
such a personal little show that people
feel like they can target I've loved you
since forever there's this time I got to
tell you and like you you don't
understand there's a bunch of people
standing around waiting for you to tell
this story and so it's hard to shut
somebody down who's telling you nice
things yes and then I mentioned
something about how like a quaalude
about this song we do called sham people
which is a Fred Sanford's drink of
ginger ale and ripple and how we wrote a
song about it and we were trying to
recreate it but the ripple was band
along with quaaludes in the fuck-you Act
of 1978 Jimmy Carter and somebody
in the audience closed peanut farmer
must and somebody goes off about
Jimmy Carter for like five minutes like
yeah he ruined our economy and like the
Jimmy Carter's ex-lover is in the
audience and is really upset about this
and you know I mean I'm sure he was busy
and he just he would have called he
would have called you back I'm sure and
like you start going off on that guy and
that's free material I want I do wish we
went to see that Florence in the Machine
show last night I wish I would have seen
her get a real heckling would have been
hilarious aying such unhackable things
yeah unless you're just an asshole yeah
like I wouldn't actually do the heckles
I could write them for someone what
she's seeing like I bet I could heckle
it well there was a loud technical issue
the microphones went crazy before it's a
machine I'll heckle you this is good so
it went mmm is everybody here that
because I'm always told that's just the
sound of angels yes
yeah you know it works anytime that's a
good fastball yeah ma I'll do it I'll do
it different heck this is just six are
you saying it's the duct tape of a soul
showing your age in your face your skin
is loose loose skin you caused 9/11 you
know I think I gotta go you gotta go I'm
going to go wash my junk because I'm
gonna see you later tonight I got to
tell you where to go tonight
yeah oh yeah you got to listen to him
Blues Traveler has a brand new album out
hurry up and hang around it's actually
out Friday October 12th so absolutely
check him out you get out on tour yes
Friday and we keep going till
Thanksgiving Friday we're Montclair New
Jersey at the well Mount yeah I think we
hit around eight eight o'clock I don't
know if you recall I was going to tell
the story of what I've learned now as
someone who has people asking them for
tickets yeah before John goes you want
to come to my show tonight the Highline
Ballroom I call them like two hours
later like yes I'm bringing 13 people
he's like I'll do it man but that's not
really a cool request though isn't it
I'm like oh boy we'll be right back it's
the bonfire
that harmonica was right next to me
suck my tea Buster will somebody take it
home I have the power
by the way taking home I promise you
he's got 40 40 on them man I didn't look
at his lips he goes no no there's
coconut though poppers harmonica
what a wind take that home buddy it's
the bonfire Comedy Central radio sirius
XM 95 give you a little harp on your
plugs yeah turn off that damn player
hoorah I'll do John popper bare hands
harder we'll be at the DC Trap House
Washington DC October 11th through 13th
then on Sunday in Maryland after that in
San Diego back in comedy company October
19 was you actually this is an
instrument to play I thought I was
nailing the John popper part when she
sounded beautiful you sound like an
angel
[Music]
you